se rompe una barrera otra más el turismo
espacial nunca antes un cohete había
estado en órbita sin una zona a otra
profesional a diferencia de las
recientes dimisiones de los
multimillonarios richard branson y jeff
bezos en esta ocasión cuatro personas al
margen del ámbito espacial estarán
alrededor de la tierra durante tres días
otro multimillonario jáled isaac man
pagó una cifra no revelada por este
viaje y decidió que sus acompañantes
fueran tres desconocidos una trabajadora
de la salud un ingeniero y una profesora
estos dos últimos ganadores de sus
asientos en un concurso todos se
entrenaron a lo largo de seis meses
estamos muy centrados en asegurarnos que
cada momento que estemos en órbita sea
para la gente y las causas que más nos
interesan esas causas más allá del
capricho de viajar por el espacio son
hacer un llamado para conseguir 100
millones de dólares en donaciones para
un hospital infantil y monitorear el
ritmo cardíaco sueño y capacidades
cognitivas en el espacio para los
amateurs de la gravedad